[Music]
there are populations across the world
covet 19 vaccines are struggling to
reach
some of the world's poorest countries
and communities are also some of the
most jab weary
countering deeply held beliefs is a tall
order especially when historic
inequality in healthcare itself
is partly to blame but one campaign in
berlin
is paving away how can skepticism in
these groups
be overcome hello and welcome to your
covet 19 special
i'm chris colbert in berlin here in the
german capital the vaccination campaign
across the city's refugee shelters was
delayed in large parts
because of supply issues but also by the
spread of misinformation
mainly on social media with the help of
an education campaign
vaccination take-up is now increasing
back to a little normality in this
refugee shelter in berlin
sewing classes resumed today the
inhabitants are delighted
for most of the pandemic their home was
very very quiet
i was in touch with many people before
corona and i used to go out a lot
but now i cannot meet up due to the
pandemic it is very difficult for me
i want the pandemic to end so we can
have contact with other people again
but although some residents know that
getting vaccinated helps protect
others and might end the pandemic most
are wary of getting the jab
that's why this group of doctors social
workers and interpreters visit refugee
homes
to convince the most reluctant to sign
up for an appointment
many people were very afraid they would
become infertile
or get thrombosis this was much
discussed in the media which also
steered up fear amongst the residents
due to the high risk of infection in
shelters refugees were
almost top priority in germany's
vaccination efforts
but various delivery bottlenecks and
approval issues have delayed the
campaign
even though this is now sorted out
social workers says it takes a lot of
convincing for
people to take the jab
it is important that you make them feel
acknowledged and show there's no
wrong question and we use interpreters
so refugees can ask questions in their
native language
articulate themselves better feel more
at ease in the conversation
by the end of the afternoon the doctors
have met with around 20 people
face-to-face contact is key to success
in some refugee shelters readiness to
get vaccinated has jumped up to 80
percent
as a result of the information campaign
for more let's bring in lena simmet
she's a senior researcher on poverty and
inequality at human rights watch welcome
to dw lina
in our report we just learned about the
reservations people in refugee camps
have towards getting vaccinated do you
see a similar pattern with people living
in other
precarious conditions
thank you so much for having me i
absolutely do so what we see is that the
the high inequality especially economic
inequality
that existed before the pandemic has
really translated into
um concerns in terms of access to to
vaccines and also
the interactions with governments since
many of the populations
had been left behind by governments for
so many years and decades
um so in so this is really not unique
uh to refugee populations in fact in
the united states we see that uh black
and brown people often
who had disproportionately higher
infection rates
um initially also had more hesitancy
towards the vaccine
out of the fear of cost so what what are
some of the cost implications
but also due to a long-standing neglect
of the government and mistrust in the
government
now these vaccination drives
nevertheless are part of the reason why
the economy at least in many countries
in the west is picking up again
but you say that low-income households
are at a particular disadvantage
in that recovery why is that
it certainly depends on the country
context i would say
um interestingly even to take a step
back i think what we see
is that the global inequality meaning
inequality between countries
here's a huge risk that low-income
countries will be
falling further behind as we see this in
equality and access to vaccines
with a higher income countries having
hoarded much of them
and and now having disproportionate
access to them
but at the country level um there have
already been signs
of of the lack of transparency and
access to vaccines
corruption that often favor certain
groups
in in getting access earlier and here
low-income people have been a
disadvantage another reason why
is that in low-income communities and
neighborhoods
healthcare is often lacking and it's not
available to the same extent
so people have to travel far distances
to reach a healthcare center
and get access to the vaccine if we look
at the
economic impact of this pandemic million
millions have lost their job during this
time of crisis around the world
particularly in the service sector
and in low-paying jobs now with
economies reopening
won't these jobs won't these
opportunities for people
come back
not necessarily and what is very
concerning
is that we saw that especially
low-income jobs
have been lost at a much higher rate
than
well-paying jobs and one of the concerns
is as countries open back up those won't
come back to the same extent
we've seen this in previous crises and
recessions
after the 2008 crisis for example we saw
that many of the low-paying jobs have
not come back
and many people who were pushed into
poverty or unemployment
did not necessarily get rehired
once the country recovered and so one
piece that we're really pushing for is
for countries in a recovery phase
to consider the the employment effects
and the long-standing effects especially
on low-income people now
speaking of recovery to varying degrees
governments have been trying to support
people that have been
particularly hit by the pandemic are you
worried that this sort of support could
be a one-time effect
very much so it's it's been an
extraordinary year
and we've seen countries respond to the
crisis in ways
they never have before so the the
amounts of money that have been poured
into relief programs into stimulus
packages
has been quite um impressive
but we at human rights watch we've done
analysis in about um
two dozen countries and what we've about
the relief programs and what we've seen
is that many
measures were highly temporary in terms
of cash payments that receive
populations at one time
but aside from that we are also
concerned as countries have taken on
more and more debt to finance these
recovery and relief programs that as
countries have to service these stats
they will introduce harsh austerity
programs that are harmful to human
rights
they may rely increasingly on the
private sector to deliver
essential public services such as
healthcare
education and they may
conduct further cuts to social
protection programs that are so
essential to protecting people from
poverty and inequality
lena senior researcher at human rights
watch
thank you for your thoughts thank you
and up next is our science correspondent
derek williams
answering your questions about the
pandemic
how does covet 19 tend to affect young
adults
there are two facets of this this
multi-faceted question that i'd like to
talk about
um the first is of course the
straightforward issue
of what the virus does physically to an
average young adult
as compared to someone who's older and
and there the statistics tell a pretty
clear story
covid19 mortality increases
dramatically with age let's look at
recent data from the u.s
more than four in five deaths there have
occurred
in those over 65 and and fewer than
one in 200 reported deaths have been in
people
under 30. um but as vaccinations rise
among the elderly
in countries like the us doctors say
that the average
age of patients who are being
hospitalized with the disease
is dropping dramatically and that many
of those younger patients
will end up with conditions like
crippling damage to the lungs or the
heart
so although covid19 is a lot less likely
to kill
a young adult there are still really
pressing reasons to get vaccinated
because
getting it can have devastating
long-term health consequences
the second important facet of this
question is
is the pandemic's emotional social
psychological and economic impact
it's affecting everyone of every age but
his
experts say in many ways
hitting young adults especially hard and
and at a key time in their lives they're
now warning that due
to lockdowns and other measures
generation covid is facing shortfalls
in opportunities for for crucial
self-development
many young people are rising to the
challenges but
but psychologists and other therapists
in many places
like like here in germany are also
currently being
overwhelmed by this tidal wave
of young adults in need of help and
and a lot of those professionals now say
that even
the serious toll taken by infection in
today's young adults
could in the long run be overshadowed by
the impact
covet 19 has on the group's mental
health
[Music]
and before we go taiwan has produced its
first homegrown covet 19 vaccine
medicine vaccine biologics has applied
to the
taiwanese government for emergency
authorization
of the job taiwan is currently facing a
surge of domestic infections
made worse by a shortage of vaccines
less than five percent of the population
have so far been inaugurated
that's our show for more you can always
hit our website at dw.com
kovit19 i'm chris coburn berlin thanks
for watching
stay safe
[Music]